today i'd like to tell you about a piece
of math known as holomorphic dynamics
this is the field which studies things
like the mandelbrot set and in fact one
of my main goals today is to show you
how this iconic shape the poster child
of math pops up in a more general way
than the initial definition might
suggest
now this field is also intimately tied
to what we talked about in the last
video with newton's fractal and another
goal of ours towards the end of this
video will be to help tie up some of the
loose ends that we had there
[Music]
so first of all this word holomorphic
might seem a little weird it refers to
functions that have complex number
inputs and complex number outputs and
which you can also take a derivative of
basically what it means to have a
derivative in this context is that when
you zoom in to how the function behaves
near a given point to the point and its
neighbors it looks roughly like scaling
and rotating like multiplying by some
complex constant we'll talk more about
that in just a bit but for now know that
it includes most of the ordinary
functions that you could write down
things like polynomials exponentials
trig functions all of that
the relevant dynamics in the title here
comes from asking what happens when you
repeatedly apply one of these functions
over and over in the sense of evaluating
on some input then evaluating the same
function on whatever you just got out
and then doing that again
and again and again and again
sometimes the pattern of points emerging
from this gets trapped in a cycle
other times the sequence will just
approach some kind of limiting point
or maybe the sequence gets bigger and
bigger and it flies off to infinity
which mathematicians also kind of think
of as approaching a limit point just the
point at infinity
and other times still they have no
pattern at all and they behave
chaotically
what's surprising is that for all sorts
of functions that you might write down
when you try to do something to
visualize when these different possible
behaviors arise it often results in some
insanely intricate fractal pattern
those of you who watched the last video
have already seen one neat example of
this there's this algorithm called
newton's method which finds the root of
some polynomial p and the way it works
is to basically repeatedly iterate the
expression x minus p of x divided by p
prime of x v prime being the derivative
when your initial seed value is in the
loose vicinity of a root to that
polynomial a value where p of x equals 0
this procedure produces a sequence of
values that really quickly converges to
that root this is what makes it a useful
algorithm in practice
but then we tried to do this in the
complex plane looking at the many
possible seed values and asking which
root in the complex plane each one of
these seed values might end up on
then we associated a color with each one
of the roots and then colored each pixel
of the plane based on which root a seed
value starting at that pixel would
ultimately land on
the results we got were some of these
insanely intricate pictures with these
rough fractal boundaries between the
colors
now in this example if you look at the
function that we're actually iterating
say for some specific choice of a
polynomial like z cubed minus one you
can rewrite the whole expression to look
like one polynomial divided by another
mathematicians call these kinds of
functions rational functions
and if you forget the fact that this
arose from newton's method you could
reasonably ask what happens when you
iterate any other rational function and
in fact this is exactly what the
mathematicians pierre fatou and gaston
julia did in the years immediately
following world war 1 and they built up
a surprisingly rich theory of what
happens when you iterate these rational
functions which is particularly
impressive given that they had no
computers to visualize any of this the
way that you and i can i think this
distinguishes julia as easily being one
of the greatest mathematicians of all
time who had no nose now remember those
two names they'll come up a bit later
by far the most popularized example of a
rational function that you might study
like this and the fractals that can
ensue is one of the simplest functions z
squared plus c
where c is some constant
i'm going to guess that this is at least
somewhat familiar to many of you but it
certainly doesn't hurt to quickly
summarize the story here since it can
help set the stage for what comes later
for this game we're going to think of c
as a value that can be changed and it'll
be visible as this movable yellow dot
for the actual iterative process we will
always start with an initial value of z
equals zero
so after iterating this function once
doing z squared plus c you get c
if you iterate a second time plugging in
that value to the function you get c
squared plus c
and as i change around the value c here
you can kind of see how the second value
moves in lockstep
then we can plug in that second value to
get z3 and that third value to get z4
and continue on like this visualizing
our chain of values
so if i keep doing this many different
times for the first many values for some
choices of c this process remains
bounded you can still see it all on the
screen and other times it looks like it
blows up and you can actually show that
if it gets as big as two it'll blow up
to infinity
if you color the points of the plane
where it stays bounded black and you
assign some other gradient of colors to
the divergent values based on how
quickly the process rushes off to
infinity you get one of the most iconic
images in all of math the mandelbrot set
now this interactive dots and stick
visualization of the trajectory by the
way is heavily inspired by ben sparks
illustration in the number file video he
did about the mandelbrot set which is
great you should watch it i honestly
thought it was just too fun not to
re-implement here i would also highly
recommend the interactive article on
echo.net about all of this stuff for any
of you who haven't had the pleasure of
reading that yet
what's nice about the ben sparks
illustration is how it illuminates what
each different part of the mandelbrot
set actually represents
this largest cardioid section includes
the values of c so that the process
eventually converges to some limit
the big circle on the left represents
the values where the process gets
trapped in a cycle between two values
and then the top and bottom circles show
values where the process gets trapped in
a cycle of three values
and so on like this each one of these
little islands kind of has its own
meaning
also notice there is an important
difference between how this mandelbrot
set and the newton fractals we were
looking at before are each constructed
beyond just a different underlying
function
for the mandelbrot set we have a
consistent seed value z equals zero but
the thing we're tweaking is the
parameter c changing the function itself
so what you're looking at is what we
might call a parameter space
but with newton's fractal we have a
single unchanging function
but what we associate with each pixel is
a different seed value for the process
of course we could play the same game
with the map z squared plus c we could
fix c at some constant and then let the
pixels represent the different possible
initial values z naught
so whereas each pixel of the mandelbrot
set corresponds to a unique function the
images on the right each just correspond
to a single function
as we change the parameter c it changes
the entire image on the right and again
just to be clear the rule being applied
is that we color pixels black if the
process remains bounded and then apply
some kind of gradient to the ones that
diverge away to infinity based on how
quickly they diverge to infinity
in principle and it's kind of
mind-warping to think about there is
some four-dimensional space of all
combinations of c and z-naught and what
we're doing here is kind of looking
through individual two-dimensional
slices of that unimaginable
pattern you'll often hear or read the
images on the right being referred to as
julia sets or julia fractals and when i
first learned about all this stuff i'll
admit that i kind of was left with the
misconception that this is what the term
julius refers to specifically the z
squared plus c case and moreover that
it's referring to the black region on
the inside
however the term julia set has a much
more general definition and it would
refer just to the boundaries of these
regions not the interior
to set the stage for a more specific
definition and to also make some headway
towards the first goal that i mentioned
at the start it's worth stepping back
and really just picturing yourself as a
mathematician right now discovering all
of this
what would you actually do to construct
a theory around this it's one thing to
look at some pretty pictures but what
sorts of questions would you ask if you
actually want to understand it all
in general if you want to understand
something complicated a good place to
start is to ask if there are any parts
of the system that have some simple
behavior preferably the simplest
possible behavior
and in our example that might mean
asking when does the process just stay
fixed in place meaning f z is equal to z
that's a pretty boring set of dynamics i
think you'd agree
we call a value with this property a
fixed point of the function in the case
of the functions arising from newton's
method by design they have a fixed point
at the roots of the relevant polynomial
you can verify for yourself if p of z is
equal to zero then the entire expression
is simply equal to z that's what it
means to be a fixed point
if you're into exercises you may enjoy
pausing for a moment and computing the
fixed points of this mandelbrot set
function z squared plus c
more generally any rational function
will always have fixed points since
asking when this expression equals z can
always be rearranged as finding the
roots of some polynomial expression
and from the fundamental theorem of
algebra this must have solutions
typically as many solutions as the
highest degree in this expression
incidentally this means that you could
also find those fixed points using
newton's method but maybe that's a
little bit too meta for us right now
now just asking about fixed points is
maybe easy but a key idea for
understanding the full dynamics and
hence the diagrams that we're looking at
is to understand stability
we say that a fixed point is attracting
if nearby points tend to get drawn in
towards it and repelling if they're
pushed away
and this is something that you can
actually compute explicitly using the
derivative of the function
symbolically when you take derivatives
of complex functions it looks exactly
the same as it would for real functions
so something like z squared has a
derivative of 2 times z
but geometrically there's a really
lovely way to interpret what this means
for example at the input 1 the
derivative of this particular function
evaluates to be 2 and what that's
telling us is that if you look at a very
small neighborhood around that input and
you follow what happens to all the
points in that little neighborhood as
you apply the function in this case z
squared
then it looks just like you're
multiplying by two this is what a
derivative of two means
to take another example let's look at
the input i
we know that this function moves that
input to the value negative one that's i
squared
but the added information that its
derivative at this value is 2 times i
gives us the added picture that when you
zoom in around that point and you look
at the action of the function on this
tiny neighborhood it looks like
multiplication by 2i
which in this case is saying it looks
like a 90 degree rotation combined with
a expansion by a factor of two
for the purposes of analyzing stability
the only thing we care about here is the
growing and shrinking factor the
rotational part doesn't matter so if you
compute the derivative of a function at
its fixed point and the absolute value
of this result is less than one it tells
you that the fixed point is attracting
that nearby points tend to come in
towards it
if that derivative has an absolute value
bigger than one it tells you the fixed
point is repelling it pushes away its
neighbors
for example if you work out the
derivative of our newton's map
expression and you simplify a couple
things a little bit here's what you
would get out
so if z is a fixed point which in this
context means that it's one of the roots
of the polynomial p
this derivative is not only smaller than
one it's equal to zero
these are sometimes called super
attracting fixed points since it means
that a neighborhood around these points
doesn't merely shrink it shrinks a lot
and again this is kind of by design
since the intent of newton's method is
to produce iterations that fall towards
a root as quickly as they can pulling up
our z squared plus c example if you did
the first exercise to find its fixed
points the next step would be to ask
when is at least one of those fixed
points attracting for what values of c
is this going to be true
and then if that's not enough of a
challenge try using the result that you
find to show that this condition
corresponds to the main cardioid shape
of the mandelbrot set this is something
you can compute explicitly it's pretty
cool
a natural next step would be to ask
about cycles and this is where things
really start to get interesting
if f z is not z but some other value and
then that value comes back to z it means
that you've fallen into a two cycle
you could explicitly find these kinds of
two cycles by evaluating f of f of z
and then setting it equal to z
for example with the z squared plus c
map f f z expands out to look like this
it's a little messy but you know it's
not too terrible the main thing to
highlight is that it boils down to
solving some degree four equation
you should note though that the fixed
points will also be solutions to this
equation so technically the two cycles
are the solutions to this minus the
solutions to the original fixed point
equation
and likewise you can use the same idea
to look for n cycles by composing f with
itself n different times
the explicit expressions that you would
get quickly become insanely messy but
it's still elucidating to ask how many
cycles would you expect based on this
hypothetical process if we stick with
our simple z squared plus c example
as you compose it with itself you get a
polynomial with degree 4 and then one
with degree 8 and then degree 16 and so
on and so on exponentially growing the
order of the polynomial
so in principle if i asked you how many
cycles are there with a period of 1
million
you can know that it's equivalent to
solving some just absolutely insane
polynomial expression with a degree of 2
to the 1 million
so again fundamental theorem of algebra
you would expect to find something on
the order of 2 to the 1 million points
in the complex plane which cycle in
exactly this way
and more generally for any rational map
you'll always be able to find values
whose behavior falls into a cycle with
period n it ultimately boils down to
solving some probably insane polynomial
expression
and just like with this example the
number of such periodic points will grow
exponentially with n
i didn't really talk about this in the
last video about newton's fractal but
it's sort of strange to think that there
are infinitely many points that fall
into some kind of cycle even for a
process like this
in almost all cases though these points
are somewhere on the boundary between
those colored regions and they don't
really come up in practice because the
probability of landing on one of them is
zero
what matters for actually falling into
one of these is if one of the cycles is
attracting in the sense that a
neighborhood of points around a value
from that cycle would tend to get pulled
in towards that cycle
a highly relevant question for someone
interested in numerical methods is
whether or not this newton's map process
ever has an attracting cycle because if
there is it means there's a non-zero
chance that your initial guess gets
trapped in that cycle and it never finds
a root
the answer here is actually yes
more explicitly if you try to find the
roots of z cubed minus two z plus two
and you're using newton's method watch
what happens to a small cluster that
starts around the value zero and sort of
bounces back and forth
and well okay in this case the cluster
we started with was a little bit too big
so some of the outer points get sprayed
away but here's what it looks like if we
start with a smaller cluster
notice how all of the points genuinely
do shrink in towards the cycle between 0
and 1. it's not likely that you hit this
with a random seed but it definitely is
possible
the exercise that you could do to verify
that a cycle like this is attracting by
the way would be to compute the
derivative of f of f of z
and you check that at the input zero
this derivative has a magnitude less
than one
the thing that blew my mind a little is
what happens when you try to visualize
which cubic polynomials have attracting
cycles at all
hopefully if newton's method is going to
be at all decent at finding roots those
attracting cycles should be rare
first of all to better visualize the one
example we're looking at we could draw
the same fractal that we had before
coloring each point based on what root
the seed value starting at that point
will tend to
but this time we'll have an added
condition of coloring points that says
that if the seed value never gets close
enough to a root at all we will color
the pixel black
notice if i tweak the roots meaning that
we're trying out different cubic
polynomials it's actually really hard to
find any place to put them so that we
see any black pixels at all
i can find this one little sweet spot
here but it's definitely rare
now what i want is some kind of way to
visualize every possible cubic
polynomial at once with a single image
in a way that shows which ones have
attracting cycles
luckily it turns out that there is a
really simple way to test whether or not
one of these polynomials has an
attracting cycle
all you have to do is look at the seed
value which sits at the average of the
three roots this center of mass here
turns out this is not at all obvious if
there's an attracting cycle you can
guarantee that this seed value will fall
into that attracting cycle
in other words if there are any black
points this will be one of them
if you want to know where this magical
fact comes from it stems from a theorem
of our good friend fatou he showed that
if one of these rational maps has an
attracting cycle you can look at the
values where the derivative of your
iterated function equals zero and at
least one of those values has to fall
into the cycle
that might seem like a little bit of a
weird fact but the loose intuition is
that if a cycle is going to be
attracting at least one of its values
should have a very small derivative
that's where the shrinking will come
from
and this in turn means that that value
in the cycle sits near some point where
the derivative is not merely small but
equal to zero
and that point ends up being close
enough to get sucked into the cycle
this fact also justifies why with the
mandelbrot set where we're only using
one seed value z equals zero it's still
enough to get us a very full and
interesting picture if there's a stable
cycle to be found that one seed value is
definitely going to find it
i feel like maybe i'm assigning a little
too much homework and exercises today
but if you're into that yet another
pleasing one would be to look back at
the derivative expression that we found
with our function that arises from
newton's method and use this wonderful
theorem of tattoos to show our magical
fact about cubic polynomials that it
suffices to just check this midpoint
over the roots
honestly though all of those are details
that you don't really have to worry
about the upshot is that we can perform
a test for whether or not one of these
polynomials has an attracting cycle by
looking at just a single point not all
of them
and because of this we can actually
generate a really cool diagram the way
this will work is to fix two roots in
place let's say putting them at z equals
negative one and z equals positive one
and then we'll move around that third
root which i'll call lambda
remember the key feature that we're
looking for is when the point at the
center of mass is black
so what i'll do is draw a second diagram
on the right where each pixel
corresponds to one possible choice of
lambda
what we're going to do is color that
pixel based on the color of this
midpoint of the three roots
if this feels a little bit confusing
that's totally okay there are kind of a
lot of layers at play here
just remember each pixel on the right
corresponds to a unique polynomial as
determined by this parameter lambda
in fact you might call this a parameter
space sound familiar
points in this parameter space are
colored black if and only if
the newton's method process for the
corresponding polynomial produces an
attracting cycle
again don't worry if that takes a little
moment to digest
now at first glance it might not look
like there are any black points at all
on this diagram
and this is good news it means that in
most cases newton's method will not get
sucked into cycles like this
but and i think i've previewed this
enough that you know exactly where this
is going if we zoom in we can find a
black region and that black region looks
exactly like a mandelbrot set
yet again asking a question where we
tweak a parameter for one of these
functions
yields this iconic cardioid and bubbles
shape
the upshot is that this shape is not as
specific to the z squared plus c example
as you might think it seems to relate to
something more general and universal
about parameter spaces with processes
like this
still one pressing question is why we
get fractals at all
in the last video i talked about how the
diagrams for newton's method have this
very peculiar property where if you draw
a small circle around the boundary of a
colored region that circle must actually
include all available colors from the
picture
and this is true more generally for any
rational map if you were to assign
colors to regions based on which
limiting behavior points fall into like
which limit point or which limit cycle
or does it tend to infinity
then tiny circles that you draw either
contain points with just one of those
limiting behaviors or they contain
points with all of them it's never
anything in between
so in the case where there's at least
three colors this property implies that
our boundary could never be smooth since
along a smooth segment you can draw a
small enough circle that touches just
two colors not all of them and
empirically this is what we see no
matter how far you zoom in these
boundaries are always rough and
furthermore you might notice that as we
zoom in you can always see all available
colors within the frame
this doesn't explain rough boundaries in
the context where there's only two
limiting behaviors but still it's a
loose end that i left in that video
worth tying up and it's a nice excuse to
bring in two important bits of
terminology julia sets and fatou sets
if a point eventually falls into some
stable predictable pattern we say that
it's part of the fattoo set of our
iterated function
and for all the maps that we've seen
this includes almost everything
the julia set is everything else which
in the pictures we've seen would be the
rough boundaries between the colored
regions what happens as you transition
from one stable attractor to another
for example the julia set will include
all of the repelling cycles and the
repelling fixed points
a typical point from the julia set
though will not be a cycle it'll bounce
around forever with no clear pattern
now if you look at a point in the fat
two set and you draw a small enough disc
around it as you follow the process that
small disc will eventually shrink as you
fall into whatever the relevant stable
behavior is
unless you're going to infinity but you
could kind of think of that as the disk
shrinking around infinity but maybe that
just confuses matters
by contrast if you draw a small disk
around a point on the julia set it tends
to expand over time
as the points from within that circle go
off and kind of do their own things
in other words points of the julia set
tend to behave chaotically their nearby
neighbors even very nearby will
eventually fall into qualitatively
different behaviors
but it's not merely that this disk
expands a pretty surprising result key
to the multi-color property mentioned
before is that if you let this process
play out that little disk eventually
expands so much that it hits every
single point on the complex plane with
at most two exceptions
this is known as the stuff goes
everywhere principle of julia sets
okay it's not actually called that in
the source i was reading from it's
mentioned as a corollary to something
known as montel's theorem but it should
be called that in some sense what this
is telling us is that the points of the
julia set are not merely chaotic they're
kind of as chaotic as they possibly can
be
here let me show you a little simulation
using the newton's map with a cluster of
a few thousand points all starting from
within a tiny tiny distance one one
millionth from a point on the julia set
of course the stuff goes everywhere
principle is about the uncountably
infinitely many points that would lie
within that distance and that they
eventually expand out to hit everything
on the plane except possibly two points
but this little cluster should still
give the general idea a small finite
sample from that tiny disk gets sprayed
all over the place in seemingly all
directions
what this means for our purposes is that
if there's some attractive behavior of
our map something like an attracting
fixed point or an attracting cycle you
can be guaranteed that the values from
that tiny disk around the point on the
julia set no matter how tiny it was will
eventually fall into that attracting
behavior
if we have a case with three or more
attracting behaviors this gives us some
explanation for why the julia set is not
smooth why it has to be complicated
even still this might not be entirely
satisfying because it kicks the can one
more step down the road raising the
question of why this stuff goes
everywhere principle is true in the
first place
like i mentioned it comes from something
called montel's theorem and i'm choosing
not to go into the details there because
honestly it's a lot to cover
the proof i could find ends up leaning
on something known as the j function
which is a whole intricate story in its
own right i will of course leave links
and resources in the description for any
of you who are hungry to learn more
and if you know of a simpler way to see
why this principle is true i'm
definitely all ears
i should also say as a brief side note
that even though the pictures we've seen
so far have a julia set which has an
area of zero it's kind of the boundary
between these regions there are examples
where the julia set is the entire plane
everything behaves chaotically which is
kind of wild
the main takeaway for this particular
section is the link between the chaos
and the fractal
at first it seems like these are merely
analogous to each other you know
newton's method turns out to be a kind
of messy process for some seed values
and this messiness is visible one way by
following the trajectory of a particular
point and another way by the complexity
of our diagrams but those feel like
qualitatively different kinds of
messiness maybe it makes for a nice
metaphor but nothing more
however what's neat here is that when
you quantify just how chaotic some of
the points are
well that quantification leads us to an
actual explanation for the rough fractal
shape via this boundary property
quite often you see chaos and fractals
sort of married together in math and to
me at least it's satisfying whenever
that marriage comes with a logical link
to it rather than as two phenomena that
just happened to coincide
[Music]
you